Super Smash Brothers has had a
complicated competitive history diehard
fans are still playing melee a 17 year
old game for the Nintendo GameCube
without much support from Nintendo
meanwhile a generation of younger fans
cut their competitive teeth on parole a
2008 game for the Wii before most of
them moved on to the Super Smash
Brothers for the Wii U well many smash
players from either game are fine with a
divide there are others who would like
to see smashers of every stripe
competing together in one game with
Nintendo's blessing I like all the smash
games and I wish both community to just
work together more often to ghost and an
e3 2018 we got to see a glimpse of what
that future might look like and what the
competitive future of Smash ultimate
could be so a new smash game is a pretty
huge source of excitement for a lot of
people it's one of those have those
biggest franchises if only because it
contains characters from all their
franchises and smash ultimate doesn't
look like it's going to be any different
and as part of their attempt to generate
excitement on the game and hena invited
eight of the best melee and smash 4
players to play in a promotional
tournament at e3 similar to something
they did in 2014 for smash 4 in 2014
chilean brawl player Gonzalo zero
Barrios beat melee legend Juan hungrybox
to viedma in a moment that zero credits
with kick-starting history
brothers for Wii U tournament zero
it was the first sign that zero was
going to become a smash alleged and
after a slight misstep in the next
tournament zero went on a fifty six
tournament win streak a run that
included winning emo 2015 without
dropping a single game as the years went
on heroes dominance wax and wane but
somehow whenever there was a big
tournament zero would always find his
way back to the top and after three
straight years of being ranked the
number one smash war player zero retired
saying he'd only come back to compete if
there was a new smash game or a
significant enough update to smash forth
to keep him interesting with no regrets
at this point I can walk forward from
this that's what I wanted to do and as
if to taunt zero a new smash game was
announced just two months after his
retirement and with it a new
Invitational to test euros metal and to
see if he still had what it took to be a
champion
[Music]
admittedly the invitational wasn't
exactly playing by official tournament
rules but as the bracket went on things
got more serious and Veerappan himself
facing off against Leonardo m'kay Leo
Lopez Perez one of the challengers 2-0
smash for round leah was ranked second
in the world in the first half of 2017
and while he dipped a little bit in the
back half he was on a hot streak going
into e3 with winds at switch fest and
get on my level and it's very dominant
fashion
give it up to him get on my level 2018
hello Leo is still in contention to be
the best smash 4 player in the world
now that 0 is out of the conversation
and he was one of just a few players to
hold victories over 0 after his
incredible win streak and here comes a
chance my gosh and at first things
looked close zero though showing that
Snape is nothing with that up smash
catching his lady yeah Jordan 0 beat
layup who then put on a show in the
lugar final using bayonetta apparent for
many fans were hoping the senior but you
see fluff at 106
and that is okay
they can flop and really for a ride at
the top of the screen for several kos
right there hopefully those nerfs stick
in the final build back in the grand
finals Leo took the fight to zero in the
first set beating him - oh we have a
bracket reset MK Leo taking two games
from zero but somehow after taking
something of a drubbing in the first set
so you're a bounce-back he was playing
the game differently understandings a
new game in ways that literally no one
had before but look look at this drift
back oh I think that's a hole done
I say hole done oh you see that drift
and after a smooth two-one-zero emerged
victorious winning a second straight
smash Invitational and showing the world
who the best smash player really is but
that's not to say that zero is out of
retirement for good
in fact he still defends as to whether
or not he'll be back to compete and
ultimate if I feel like I can make good
money with this game and actually make
the effort worth then I will unretire
and in the meantime we still have a few
months left to play out for smash 4 Leo
won evo Japan but it remains to be seen
if he can repeat that victory on the
world stage at Evo 2018 which will
probably be the last Evo that smash 4
will be played at before it gets
inevitably replaced by ultimate but zero
coming out of retirement even for just
one event and playing against one a
smash force current best in a high-level
match in a game that isn't even done yet
that bodes well for ultimate future well
it probably won't be the game that
unites both the smash 4 and the melee
communities I'm gonna tell you something
you might not like you
there's never gonna be another mailing
ultimate had a great first showing all
things to a storyline years in the
making
goal thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]